[Applause]
happy wednesday everybody uh so i see
why am i
that's short for in case you missed it
does that help
oh yeah
okay screw everybody
president biden threw an inflation
reduction party yesterday but maybe you
had something more pleasant to do like
jamming a hedge trimmer into your rectum
don't judge
he held it on the white house lawn
because he couldn't remember where the
front door was
and this way he wouldn't pee on the rugs
plus that lawn can always use some extra
fertilizer
now he threw this party even as
inflation hit 8.3 percent his staff
wanted to cancel but jill had already
told joe there would be balloons clouds
and a pony
but it felt like they were throwing a
surprise birthday party for a corpse
then watching that corpse drone on for
25 minutes
it's funny at most memorials you never
wonder when's this stiff gonna shut up
and really is the economy something joe
should be celebrating
it's like the washington generals
throwing a parade after a season of
playing the harlem globetrotters
hooray we went zero in 82.
it's like al baldwin giving himself an a
in marksmanship
but something happened
it's like brian kilmeade throwing
himself a book party
and it always sucks when reality reigns
on your fantasy as biden boasted of his
phony accomplishment the stock market
sank faster than joe's nose in a nearby
ponytail
the dow plunged 1200 points that's one
of the largest drops since joy behar
tried to sit in a beanbag chair
terrible
food prices continue to climb housing's
drying up and yet joe continues to
gaslight us like we're a frat boy's fart
you know we used to light those anyway
his first mistake inviting a newcomer to
today's music scene james taylor to open
the festivities here's a clip
oh
stop it it wasn't that bad
let's try again
i see
lonely times when i could not find
red
but i always
thought that i'd see you
baby one more time
oh i got arthritis in my fingers it
hurts
i'm james taylor
he's really aged and not in a good way
like a bag of cabbage buried in the
backyard
so old joe asked taylor to lead off with
a song called fire and rain
which is also how hunter describes the
feeling when he pees
that's
that's the joke of the night it's
apparently though about suicide and
heroin addiction which makes sense
suicide and addiction are two things
that have done well under joe
but maybe the message is yes times are
tough under biden but it could be worse
you could be forced to listen to that
song forever
that'll make you reach for the pills or
throw yourself on the sharp end of joe's
catheter
but i don't blame the white house for
grabbing taylor joe originally asked for
sinatra and before that glenn miller
sadly everyone joe's heard of has died
or was killed by hillary
but shouldn't you think
shouldn't you think about what you think
about at the time
think about what you'd think about at
the time
think about how you'd feel
if you didn't have the insurance and
didn't have the money
it's wrong it's not who we are and we're
going to fix that too um joe do us a
favor please stop fixing things
not your
forte
i mean
you're less helpful than a homeless dude
trying to squeegee your windshield with
a bottle of urine
shout out to jimmy fella hey
but at least the soul of america is
vibrant
the soul of america is vibrant
the future of america is bright and the
promise of america is real it is real it
is real
yes
be suspicious when a politician
references your soul
bad leaders rely on abstract concepts
when they can't point to concrete
successes
leave my soul out of it what about gas
prices the war
crime but i guess making progress in
every country as big and complicated as
ours is difficult
making progress in every country as big
and complicated as ours is difficult it
is not easy
and it never has been
so that's your excuse
it's hard
well i hate to tell you a sport it's
your job
and everyone before you has done a
better job i wonder if that's an
applause line
i that's an applause line
it's so cute when the brain locks horns
with the botox
but talk about bad timing a victory lap
on inflation as the inflation numbers
come out feels like joe was leading the
band playing on the titanic
just like he did back in 1912.
he performs like a demented birthday
clown as staffers forced to pretend that
they're there by choice
of course the white house touts
declining gas prices which is what
happens when people stop buying gas
because it's too high and you're
responsible for them going up in the
first place
he's like the guy who sets his
neighbor's house on fire and then wants
to be called a hero because he rescued
their cat
talk about gaslighting gas prices go up
when you buy it and gas prices drop when
you don't i'd call it a catch 22 which
is also the projected number of times
joe will get covered by january
food's up 13.5 electricity up 15.8
percent and rents up 7
health insurance a whopping 24
but ask kjp i wonder if she'll say
prices have been essentially flat in our
country these last two years months
uh prices have been essentially flat in
our country these these last two months
yeah much like a scan of your brain
i'd call her a call her a puppet but i
don't want to get a hate mail from miss
piggy
fact is
we knew inflation was coming after all
the government spending but what we
didn't expect was them saying more
government spending would solve the
problems caused by government spending
and now buy it in student loan
cancellation that's going to cost us
another half trillion so while families
are draining their savings on life's
basic needs joe is bailing out gender
studies grads reneging on loans that
they agreed to pay he's rewarding the
least deserving by punishing those who
paid their debts that's only going to
cause prices to soar but joe doesn't
care he threw himself a party and joe
will take any excuse to cut cake or the
cheese
so obvious i wonder what joe has to say
i seen anger
i seen pain
i've seen folks trying to fill their gas
tank
trying to stay sane
i left all those folks living paycheck
to paycheck out in the rain
[Music]
you know what i got to say
come on man
let's welcome
tonight's guests
i know they say dress for the job you
want but i already have a bookie box
across americo's jimmy fayla
he's so sharp his handshake will give
you splinters host of off limits with
ian howarth ian howard
she's like an ear of corn slender blonde
and goes right through you fox news
contributor cat time
and he needs a crop duster to apply
sunscreen my massive sidekick in the nwa
world television championship
jimmy as always i see you got another
part-time job you're a rodeo clown at a
petting zoo
what it is uh you know what i do look
like i look like a children's magician
who shouldn't be around children yes i
realized that when i left the house and
by the way happy birthday oh thank you
it's probably it's hard to feel older
when the waitress still brings you a
kid's menu you know what i mean good for
you nice nice anyway besides the fact it
looks like your face ate your face
[Music]
[Laughter]
the atkins diet
what do you make of the timing of all
this shouldn't they have done the right
thing and just like postponed it oh it's
so embarrassing dude yeah the fact that
they got out on the lawn yesterday and
you know in football if you win a game
they dump the gatorade on the winning
coach yeah the losing coach down 49-10
dumped the gatorade on himself yes and
it's like i'm going to disney world yeah
right to ride snow white and the seven
genders come on who's with me it was
really embarrassing and i feel like
they're in a tough place now where
they've made a calculated decision that
between now and the midterms they're
just going to claim it's working you
know what i mean because they had
candidates trying to distance themselves
from biden you know is he going to run
is he not going to run now they're like
we'll just say it's working and i think
that's what they're going to tell us
that the economy identifies as doing
well yes
that's what's going to happen
kjp is going to get up to the podium be
like the economy identifies as doing
great its pronouns are bull and
the language
the language jimmy might i remind you
that this is a family show
you have the manson family yes exactly
so ian welcome to the show first time
glad to have you here what did you make
of this whole event yesterday it felt
like donald trump planned the whole
thing really
biden's shuffling out trying not to
swallow himself the entire time
celebrating the economy that was falling
apart in the background as the stock
market literally crashed during his
speech what else could you ask for it
was fantastic for trump yeah i didn't
know you were from jersey i know i i
blend in blend in alabama actually yeah
um
do you think it's like if if trump had
actually pulled this off though i mean
he was the media would treat it far
differently it's just like this is just
another day in in biden land he just got
on a jet and went away and no one really
talked about it one positive he was back
from delaware for five minutes so i
think you should give him some credit
there right yeah he went and voted how
nice of him cat how you doing
great that's great
so there's so many there's so many
elements to this story to choose from
what interested you well
on the one hand i kind of get what they
were doing
they were probably thinking okay
if they see us having fun they see us
partying they're gonna think you know
people think everything's okay right uh
but even if i didn't know the numbers
i'm like old enough to know that
sometimes the more you see somebody
partying the
less it means everything's okay uh like
you know like you know what i mean like
if somebody breaks up with you and
you're crying all the time you don't
post that you post yourself like out of
the club having fun and you like leave
out the part where you threw up cause
you haven't eaten in three days you got
too drunk too fast
that's what they're probably doing but
we know the real story here everybody
you don't have to like know what the
exact numbers are you just go to the
grocery store and you're like that's a
lot more expensive than it used to be so
it was kind of a slap in the face to
everyone and also and especially because
as taxpayers we all paid for that party
exactly do you see those people looking
miserable out there yeah that was
fantastic but it's true it's like it's i
hate to use the word gaslight i've used
it twice it's it's stupid but it is it
but you can't gaslight somebody if you
go to the supermarket but that is what
the word means because now everybody
just uses it to be like he just cause
someone's mean to you or doesn't like
you that's not gaslighting yes i think
it's just lying yeah right tyrus this is
the biggest cover-up
since watergate yeah
thank you finally someone says it
all my years as an investigative
journalist
i'm just shocked and appalled at the
braz and behavior
in his defense he won't remember it but
while they were partying
uh i think this and i think you i think
you're right they're just going to try
to write it out everything's fine don't
pay attention it's like the wizard of oz
when he got found out what was really
troublesome to me was that this railroad
strike
is going down and once again this
administration claiming they've solved
one problem is about to make another
problem even worse
and they already started the spin where
they're trying to say that these
railroad workers want more money no they
don't they want to be able to take a day
off without getting fined for it so once
the railroads break down under this
administration he will then have another
party to throw as being the worst he's
already there but he will be the worst
president in the history of this united
states because we will all be boiling
water
because what's on the railroad ladies
and gentlemen chlorine and we can't have
clean drinking water so what we'll just
change it to the new country of flint
this is how bad this president is and
the fact that he did that you should be
we have 55 days until vote time every
one of you should be out there getting
ready to vote that's interesting
i didn't uh
i didn't put those things together that
this strike will reduce the amount of
chlorine no railroads going no
chlorine's coming yeah i guess i don't
think about chlorine yes because when
you turn your you drink bottled water or
you turn your faucet on yeah as soon as
that's gone that's your ass chlorine is
the chlorine is the jan brady of
chemicals in your water everybody talks
about marsha which is fluoride yes
fluoride is the marsha brady
jan is the chlorine yep i don't know
what cindy is
yeah you lost charcoal charcoal yeah it
could be yes why not i don't know i
think it's time to tease that's tv talk
to uh meaning going to break
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else